Released just in time for Comic-Con, here's
everything you might have missed in the first
trailer for Kevin Smith's long-awaited Jay
and Silent Bob Reboot.
As a wise man once said:
"um… snootchie bootchies?"
The title of Jay and Silent Bob Reboot tells
audiences exactly what it is a super meta
reboot of Smith's 2001 film Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back.
In the original Jay and Silent Bob Strike
Back, our dim-witted stoner protagonists traveled
to Hollywood to shut down a movie version
of Bluntman and Chronic, a comic book that
imagines Jay and Silent Bob as marijuana-themed
superheroes.
That film was lampooning Hollywood adaptations.
Jay and Silent Bob Reboot is, you guessed
it, lampooning Hollywood reboots by using
the exact same plot: the studio is now rebooting
the Bluntman and Chronic film, so Jay and
Silent Bob have to once again go to Hollywood
to stop it.
Expect a lot of fourth-wall breaking inside
jokes.
"What do you guys think about this reboot?"
"It sucks!
There, I said it.
And who's directing it?
Kevin f------ Smith?!"
Jay and Silent Bob Reboot looks to be a franchise-capping
movie, pulling characters from two decades'
worth of interconnected Kevin Smith movies.
Rosario Dawson appears in the trailer, likely
reprising her role as Becky from Clerks II.
Matt Damon found one of his earliest roles
in Smith's Dogma, and in Jay and Silent Bob
Reboot, he returns as Loki, the avenging angel
he played in the latter.
Damon's buddy Ben Affleck is also a Smith
veteran, and he appears in the trailer as
Holden McNeil, the comic book artist who created
Bluntman and Chronic in Chasing Amy.
Also on hand at that convention: Jason Biggs
and James Van Der Beek, the original Bluntman
and Chronic from the movie-inside-of-a-movie
in Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back.
And in this film as in the last Jay and Silent
Bob movie, the heroes find out about the movie
version from comics lover Brodie Bruce, still
portrayed by Jason Lee.
It's not just old friends making cameos, there
are plenty of new faces too.
In a cheeky bit of self-referential humor,
former Batman Val Kilmer plays himself, playing
Bluntman, with Supergirl's Melissa Benoist
acting as Chronic.
In other cameos from new cast members, Donnell
Rawlings from Chappelle's Show heads up a
SWAT team, Craig Robinson plays a judge, Joe
Manganiello is a bailiff, Justin Long plays
a lawyer, and Fred Armisen shows up as an
unlucky Uber-type driver.
Even some other famous screen stoners make
an appearance: rappers Method Man and Redman,
as well as the legendary Tommy Chong.
And there are also some new characters as
well.
Shannon Elizabeth reprises her role from Jay
and Silent Bob Strike Back as an old love
interest of Jay's, but this time she has a
surprise: two daughters, one of which is Jay's
love child played by Kevin Smith's actual
daughter, Harley Quinn Smith.
Everyone knows Smith is a huge comic book
fan, so it's no surprise that there are a
ton of nods to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in the Jay and Silent Bob Reboot trailer.
Chris Hemsworth, famous for playing Thor in
the MCU, shows up briefly.
Kevin Smith, as Silent Bob, gets involved
in some kind of action sequence that finds
him inside of a high-tech suit clearly inspired
by Iron Man.
David Dastmalchian, who portrayed Russian
hacker Kurt in the Ant-Man movies, makes an
appearance as a high-strung SWAT team member.
And just like in an actual Marvel movie, there's
even a Stan Lee appearance of sorts Jason
Lee can be seen wearing a T-shirt bearing
the face of the dearly departed Marvel master
and cameo king.
Finally, the first and coolest cameo in the
Jay and Silent Bob reboot trailer isn't even
by a person it's by a run down old building.
Yes, fans of Kevin Smith's Askewniverse may
recognize the building as the location of
Smith's first film, the beloved cult classic
Clerks.
We can't wait to see what other easter eggs
await when the film hits theaters on October
15th.
See you there!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.